[Música]
cuando pensamos en innovación social
para el cambio nos viene a la mente las
nuevas ideas que podemos proponer para
lograr la transformación y el desarrollo
en la sociedad
por supuesto el principio para lograr
una innovación está en la creatividad
humana
y para estas soluciones nos pueden
ayudar para resolver problemas desde dos
perspectivas
primero resolviendo problemas que han
estado durante largo tiempo afectando
digamos al los seres humanos al
desarrollo de las sociedades por ejemplo
a la hambruna en el mundo la mortalidad
infantil que son problemas que no hemos
podido resolver aún
o también identificando nuevos problemas
que se presentan por ejemplo en las
sociedades desarrolladas como el efecto
de la soledad de las personas en los
costos de los sistemas de salud por
ejemplo
y entonces se trata de identificar estos
problemas y generar soluciones creativas
pero bueno todo esto parte de un
principio basado en la solidaridad y la
capacidad que tenemos los seres humanos
de poder tener principios altruistas
hacia nuestros propios congéneres o
incluso hacia otras especies
este principio nos lleva a cuando
estamos caminando en la calle por
ejemplo encontrar a una persona que
tiene una necesidad y apoyarla hasta un
sistema no organizado en el mundo a
través de organizaciones de cooperación
internacional y nacional el trabajo que
hacen los estados por ejemplo para
resolver estos problemas de la sociedad
esta historia de trabajo con el
desarrollo pues empieza hace muchos años
hace más de 70 años y bueno empezó como
todo cometiendo tal vez muchos errores
al principio aprendiendo de estos
errores para lograr que habíamos mejores
soluciones cada vez y ahí hacer que las
personas tengan mejores oportunidades me
hace recuerdo a una anécdota que cuando
en aquellos tiempos en uno de mis
primeros trabajos me comentaban unos
colegas no llegando a una comunidad una
ong con muchos recursos levantando la
información de las necesidades de las
comunidades de las familias y bueno
haciendo una lista de compras no como
decimos con las demandas y los
requerimientos de la comunidad
entonces se dirige el jefe de la
organización hacia la comunidad dice
bueno no se preocupen compañeros vamos a
solucionar todas sus necesidades y veo
que esta comunidad que es tan bonita y
tiene tantos atractivos también necesita
un puente no entonces alguien de la
comunidad
a la mano y dice pero licenciado no
tenemos un río no se preocupen también
les construimos el río no entonces bueno
esto nos mostraba tal vez un enfoque de
trabajo que iba de arriba hacia abajo es
decir que era vertical y que mostraba el
poder del que tenía los recursos no
sobre las personas afortunadamente esto
ha ido cambiando con el tiempo y cada
vez hemos ido trabajando con un enfoque
más centrado en las personas y en los
derechos humanos es decir valorar en
realidad el derecho que tenemos todos a
tener una calidad de vida a ser felices
que algo así tan difícil tal vez y tan
fácil a la vez y por supuesto esto ha
desafiado a que tengamos cada vez
mejores enfoques de trabajo cada vez
pensemos en soluciones más prácticas
hoy en día ustedes jóvenes tienen una
oportunidad maravillosa durante los
últimos 50 años hemos avanzado en tener
condiciones de tecnología acceso a
información como
usted es su generación son las que
tienen mayor acceso a este conocimiento
y a posibilidades increíbles yo diría no
tenemos avances importantes en la
ciencia que nos han permitido conocer y
entender muchas por ejemplo fases del
desarrollo y el crecimiento de las
personas y la capacidad que podemos
construir desde los niños desde los 0
años hasta la el desarrollo adulto y
bueno vemos en esto qué
hay un hay un hay una oportunidad grande
para trabajar en el desarrollo humano y
social
y un aspecto fundamental para para la
innovación social es que entendamos en
primer lugar el contexto en el que
estamos trabajando es decir que
comprendamos cuáles son no sólo las
demandas o las necesidades de la
comunidad sino que entendamos cuáles son
los factores motivadores qué son los
factores que hacen que la comunidad se
movilice para que logre realmente un
cambio social no y este ha sido un
cambio importante en el enfoque de
trabajo porque se trata en realidad ya
no solo de que la comunidad participe
generando demandas sino realmente
participe en las soluciones y esto ha
desafiado a trabajar nuevos modelos de
trabajo con la comunidad a plantear
nuevas soluciones nuevas propuestas de
ingeniería social diríamos que permitan
que la comunidad cada vez se empodere
más y pueda ser protagonistas realmente
de su desarrollo
por supuesto aquí les comento una
experiencia que es muy conocida en el
mundo del desarrollo igual una
una ong que trabaja con un grupo de
mujeres en una comunidad y se dan cuenta
que estas mujeres estaban tenían el
problema entre comillas de que la fuente
de agua estaba muy lejana no ellas
tenían que caminar una hora hasta hasta
la fuente y traerla para sus domicilios
para poder utilizarla no está en una
tarea generalmente que se hacían las
jóvenes y las mujeres entonces bueno
llegan los técnicos de la organización y
se dan cuenta que bueno es ser un
problema como podemos ayudar a estas
mujeres se construye un sistema de agua
entonces que permite almacenarla y
trasladarla y entonces ya en la
comunidad tenían una pila pero
después de un tiempo que retornar a la
comunidad se da cuenta que no la
utilizaba mucho estos bueno piensan que
ha fallado no está mal la pila se ha
descompuesto el agua no está contaminada
empiezan a indagar un poco más y no
ninguno de estos factores eran los que
afectaban al al uso de este recurso sino
que lo que afectaba era que la gente
prefería en este caso las mujeres
preferían utilizar esta hora de tiempo
para caminar hasta la fuente porque se
convertía en un espacio de socializar de
compartir conversar informarse de las
novedades no entonces ellas no estaban
dispuestas a cambiar la comunidad de
tener la pila por este espacio social
que podían compartir no aquí tengo
algunos ejemplos de tecnologías que hoy
día están siendo utilizadas de manera
innovadora
desde la construcción miren con boca
evolucionado de inmensos sistemas para
filtrado de agua hasta el uso de
tecnología de membranas este es otro
ejemplo que me gusta
el de las letrinas ecológicas un gran
aporte en los años 80 y 90 para reducir
el consumo de agua en las familias y
hasta la idea de bill gates no
últimamente que también sigue pensando
en el mismo problema no se dan cuenta el
problema central sigue siendo cómo
resolver la disposición de los desechos
de las personas el uso de las
tecnologías espaciales nos da también
una serie de oportunidades para poder
por ejemplo hacer uso en planificación
territorial y esto nos permita digamos
planificar realmente el uso sostenible
de los recursos
también hay ahora la oportunidad y el
acceso que tenemos al desarrollo de
aplicaciones y aquí hay muchos ejemplos
que podría comentarles no desde
aplicaciones para el uso por ejemplo del
comercio electrónico para el desarrollo
de los jóvenes emprendedores con
programas
auto capacitación pero también por
ejemplo el uso de aplicaciones para el
monitoreo de la salud y la mortalidad
infantil por ejemplo no tiene
aplicaciones ustedes pueden ingresar y
están disponibles siento se diría miles
de este tipo de aplicaciones y aquí
quería traer a colar este tipo de
tecnología no está si es un poco más
moderna sólo tiene más de mil años de
antigüedad son en realidad prácticas y
tecnologías andinas no que en realidad
desarrollaron las culturas para
gestionar un problema que nos atañe
ahora no el cambio climático el mensaje
aquí es que tenemos oportunidad de usar
la tecnología que se apropie a nuestras
necesidades con la tecnología apropiada
bueno otro principio importantísimo la
inclusión de las personas cómo podemos
hacer que los grupos que de la sociedad
que entre comillas son más vulnerables
puedan acceder a estas innovaciones
puedan de cierta forma a ser
beneficiarios también de estos
desarrollos tan avanzados de la
tecnología aquí un ejemplo no ven estas
gafas fueron desarrolladas por un
científico y rita para ayudar a los
ciegos no a leer los libros pero no que
no están hechos en braille oa poder
desplazarse en vez del uso de bastones
todavía la dificultad es que esta
tecnología es costosa y no puede llegar
a digamos a las personas que tal vez lo
necesitan más pero tenemos la
oportunidad de poder utilizar esta
tecnología de sensores y a partir de
esto desarrollar muchas más soluciones
quizás que pueden ser
de mucho valor para las personas que así
lo requiere el uso y la selección de la
tecnología por lo tanto dependerá de las
condiciones que nosotros tenemos de las
oportunidades que podemos
tener para
utilizar esta tecnología en los entornos
que se apropia bien otra riqueza que
tenemos el país y es un poco el tema que
vemos que está transversal en en estas
presentaciones la diversidad que tenemos
en nuestro país es respecto a las
culturas y a las diversas formas de ver
el mundo y las visiones de desarrollo no
una riqueza que tenemos que aprovecharla
y que en cierta forma también se está
erosionando y que en realidad también
está afectando y se está perdiendo y
estamos perdiendo una oportunidad todos
y todas para poder aprovechar este
conocimiento acá una foto de el nevado
chacaltaya solo un ejemplo de los
desafíos que nos enfrentamos actualmente
ustedes y nosotros como
a habitantes de este planeta el deshielo
waka efectos del cambio climático y por
supuesto toda la degradación que se está
produciendo en el planeta acá mostrarles
una foto de un problema que estamos
hemos estado viviendo recién hace unos
días en la paso uno cuando está 15 días
sin poder disponer de la basura se da
cuenta que somos una sociedad que
necesitamos repensar nuestras formas y
nuestro consumo y de esta manera ver que
tenemos que cambiar un poco el chip no
tenemos que
y hacer realmente un uso más sostenible
de los recursos que disponemos bien para
finalizar yo quiero desafiar los jóvenes
a ustedes son una generación que tiene
que resolver ahora estos problemas que
tal vez la generación a la que yo
pertenezco no hemos podido hacer los
desafíos a pensar en ideas innovadoras
en ideas creativas para lograr un cambio
social muchas gracias
[Música]